[Music]
today we're going to be canceling
samantha lux who is a youtuber and uh
quote trans woman that is a biological
male with a youtube channel actually a
quite popular channel with well over 600
000 subscribers somehow sam has many
videos promoting transgenderism and
quite often responding to perceived
instances of transphobia
one of the most recent videos on the
channel targets if you can believe it
none other than the leading lgbt
children's author on the planet yours
truly
sam stumbled across my children's book
johnny the walrus which is still
available for pre-order over at
johnnywalrus.com by the way and and does
not approve
specifically my video where i read the
book to a group of children has provoked
sam's ire in a video titled transphobes
are writing children's books trans girl
reacts
this is good you know i am sincerely
interested to hear how a trans girl
quote unquote reacts to johnny the
walrus perhaps this will be a
point-by-point rebuttal perhaps evidence
and science and logic and bulletproof
moral arguments will all be marshaled
and by the end of the video i will have
completely changed my mind
realized the error in my ways repented
of my anti-trans beliefs
maybe even because of this video that
we'll watch together i will become trans
myself
it's possible
so let's watch some of this and see what
our friend samantha lux brings to the
table
now if you're familiar with the content
that i create here in my channel if
you're familiar with the arguments that
conservatives love to make about trans
people you would be familiar with
transphobes claim that we are
indoctrinating their children that were
making their children gay that were
forcing their young tomboy daughter to
become a boy that's not me who me who me
i would never i love you trans girl
i love your tomboy daughter she is great
what i don't love
is a hypocrite matt walsh if you are not
familiar with is like an infamous
transphobe on youtube this
posted a video one week ago reading his
book johnny the walrus to a bunch of
little kids
okay so we're off to a rough start here
uh already a few points first i do not
believe sam that you are forcing any
child to do anything
or making any child or making any child
do anything
i am accusing you and your fellow
propagandists
of trying to heavily influence children
with falsehoods distortion lies and
other forms of insanity that they the
children do not have the mental capacity
to sort through
so indoctrination does not often involve
physical force
because you cannot physically force
someone to believe something
belief requires mental assent not
physical ascent
but you can coerce and trick people into
believing things and when they're
children that's very easy to do as you
know from experience
also by the way i appreciate being
called infamous and i won't take any
issue with that label
but um i am not an infamous transphobe
because i'm not a transphobe at all
and when i say i'm not a transphobe i'm
not saying it to gain your approval or
to convince you that i'm not bigoted
yeah i couldn't give it less less of a
damn if you think that i'm a bigoted or
not it doesn't matter to me
i am instead concerned with definitions
and the definition of phobia
is irrational fear
i'm not afraid of trans people if i was
i wouldn't spend so much of my time
saying things that i know will make you
angry
my fear and it is not irrational
is of the effect that trans propaganda
has on society and especially on kids
okay so we have that clarified let's
continue we have to skip around a little
bit because sam's video is long and it
seems like a little too self-involved
even for me to spend too much time
reacting to somebody else reacting to
one of my videos but we'll watch enough
to get the gist and to discover whether
sam will be able to make any arguments
that will disprove or undermine my
central points let's keep going
all right do you understand the
comparison that's going to be happening
here he's like this book is about a
little boy who thinks he's a walrus and
his mom you know also is convinced that
he's a real walrus do you get the
correlation it's gonna be about a little
boy that thinks he's a girl or something
and the mom is convinced that he's a
real girl how creative how did you ever
come up with such a creative powerful
analogy for children
who don't understand what you're talking
about
yeah well you're right it's not creative
it's not creative at all i mean the
comparison between somebody identifying
as a different sex and someone
identified as an animal has been done a
million times i'm not the first to do it
south park did it a decade ago but the
problem is that nobody on your side has
ever come up with anything approaching
an effective response to the analogy
you've never been able to explain why
it's wrong
all you can do all you ever do is just
scoff that you've heard the point before
well we know you've heard it and you're
going to keep hearing it over and over
again until you answer it
all right let's continue
what is this thing doing on the floor
that's we don't have to worry about that
we're gonna read the book now this man
has never met a kid in his whole life
never interacted with one child he's
like i don't give a sit down we're gonna
read the book i'm here for half an hour
and then i gotta go so sit down so i can
film okay
thank you
no i think um i think the problem is
that you've never been around a dad
before which maybe i would have already
guessed
um i'm around kids all the time because
i have four of them but so i but i have
by now developed a critical case of
dad's syndrome and that means that i'm
just snapping my fingers and i'm keeping
people on task that's what i do i'm dead
you should see me during short time
every night in my house you get over
there pick up those shoes you come over
vacuum the rug
i don't even remember anybody's names
anymore
that's another symptom of dad syndrome
okay uh skipping ahead
but johnny's mom's phone said it's not
just pretend
so she went on her phone and there were
people telling her that this isn't
pretend he's really a walrus
only a bigot would say that how dare you
offend what's a bigot anybody know
kids i don't even i don't know how all
these kids are i'm not good at
estimating age but they don't know what
you're talking about you don't see their
face
did he run this past like an actual
children's author and we like read it to
a kid and see what they thought before
he published it i think he just went for
it of course they don't know what a
bigot is
they're for i mean it does make sense
that he would go for children because
you know they have the same capacity for
intellectual thought as him like babe if
you're gonna write a children's book
write it for children write it using
words that they understand and that they
know and that you don't have to explain
for them to understand what you're
trying to say through your book
um first of all don't call me babe
second did i run it by an actual
children's author yes i ran it by myself
and when myself came to myself and said
self what do you think of this
children's book idea my self-responded
self that's an exceptional idea
so i did get the go-ahead from an expert
in the field of children's literature if
that matters to you now
sam also says that that some of these
concepts are above a child's head
yes sam
that's the point
now you're getting it if a silly story
about a kid transitioning into a walrus
is inevitably too weird and abstract for
children then what happens if we mix sex
and gender into it
does it suddenly become more appropriate
for children
if a child as you say isn't even old
enough to understand what a bigot is
or to hear the word
then is he old enough to be introduced
to a concept like transgenderism
if he can't understand bigots can he
understand what it means for a boy to
have a girl mystically trapped inside
him
if my book is above his head what about
a choice that will fundamentally change
his life and alter him physically and
biologically forever
is that above his head too
what do you think
connect the dots sam you can do it
you'll need to eat worms and to put on
gray makeup
the worms give you whiskers the gray
blends you in the doctor says
and a simple procedure cuts feet into
fins
the doctor wants to cut
into johnny and make him into a walrus
it's gross eating worms mom
they're all so dang twitchy he doesn't
want any worms our children
you see what he's doing here with the
analogies that he's drawing he's arguing
that parents are forcing their young
children to take medications that they
don't want to take or to have surgeries
that they don't want to take or to
transition when they don't want to
transition that's not what happens you
know children have a say in the process
children are allowed to make their own
decision of course with the help of
medical professionals of course of
course but like this whole part that
johnny's like i don't want to eat worms
that would be the end of it that's the
end of it jordan doesn't want to eat
worms no worms for johnny
no worms
i will say we got exactly the reaction
to the doctor page with the bone saw
that that i had in mind when we included
that page and i fought for that page now
there was i would say a little bit
behind the scenes there was some
discussion
um over here uh about that particular
page with the doctor with the bone bone
saw chasing the child and i fought for
that
i said that's got to be in there
and it was no uh sam but see you say
children make their own decision but but
children can't make their own decisions
if i'm arguing that a certain course of
action
is harmful for a child bad for them
damaging to them it does no good to
retort that the child wants to do it
children who want to do harmful things
should still be prevented from doing
those things
why because they're children
they don't understand what they're
saying they don't know what they want
and often they don't actually want what
they think they want
at red robin the other day my
five-year-old told me he wanted to order
salmon
for his first dinner
now i knew damn well that that kid did
not want salmon
he wanted chicken tenders and fries
because that's what he always wants and
it's the only thing he'll ever actually
eat at a restaurant
so i didn't let him have the meal that
he wanted
because i knew that he didn't really
want it
because he's a kid
and that's just for something as
frivolous as a meal at red robin
what if your son says he wants to become
a girl
or a salmon for that matter
not only can you be sure that he doesn't
really want that because he doesn't
understand what he's saying or what it
means or what the implications are
because he can't because he's just a kid
but also in this case whereas it's it's
at least possible to actually order
salmon it's not possible for him to
actually become a girl
which is reason enough to not give him
what he says he wants
all right let's skip ahead again and see
if sam saves the best rebuttals for the
very end
what's the moral of the story what's the
lesson here aren't children's books
supposed to have like a lesson that's
you know clear because i don't know what
this is trying to say i don't know what
this lesson here is the other lesson is
don't listen to the creepy people in
your phone don't trust medical
professionals
walruses are mean like oh my goodness
maybe it's like a writing class or
something ask a kid like do you know
what this book is about
because none of them did like you could
argue that this book is made for adults
write a book for adults
write a book for adults or is it that
you have to dumb down these analogies
and these arguments for children brain
because they don't hold any weight in
actual adult language but yeah that is
it for this video what do you guys think
you're gonna go get johnny the walrus
the book
uh
well since you asked
what do i think i think you should
probably in the future have some kind of
rebuttal if you're gonna make a rebuttal
video
you rebutted my points in the same way
that my dog rebuts the deer that he sees
running through the backyard by just
barking incoherently at them
yeah you're right that i did dumb down
the arguments and analogies but
apparently i wasn't able to make them
dumb enough for you to understand
my story about a kid pretending to be a
walrus was it would seem slightly above
your reading level
and that's a shame because it's a
message that you might have really
benefited from
and instead i'm forced to say finally
samantha lux
that you are sadly tragically cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content